in the end the decision on archie
battersby's life came down to the
standard of proof
his doctors at the royal london hospital
say that it's most likely that archie
has died
his family say that in the absence of
the legally accepted brain stem test
the court should apply the criminal
standard so demanding clinicians prove
their theory beyond reasonable doubt
today the judge decided she is satisfied
to rely on a balance of probabilities
handing bart's health nhs trust a most
unusual victory in a declaration of
death without a formal brain stem test
this is a sad and difficult time for
archie's family and our thoughts and
sympathies are with them as they come to
terms with what has happened
in line with the guidance issued by the
court
our expert clinicians will provide the
best possible care
while life support is withdrawn
we are also ensuring
there is time for the family to decide
whether they wish to appeal
before any changes to care are made
it's a devastating blow to the family
absolutely the worst nightmare ever any
parent's worst nightmare over a week in
court when you
a week out of the eight weeks that was
spent in court that should have been by
a little boy's bedside archie was
admitted to hospital in april following
an incident at home that left him
relying on a mechanical ventilator to
breathe
his mother says this video shows him
gripping her hand a sign her little boy
is still alive the doctors dispute this
during weeks of hearings here at the
high court the trust said that arches
nurses were experiencing moral distress
at the prospect of resuscitating the
youngster in what they say is the
certain eventuality of his having
cardiac arrest
but this was never about the nurses
or indeed the family the judge had to
decide what is in archie's best interest
her decision to end life support
treatment may have crushed his parents
world
but they have vowed to appeal
sardia chowdhury sky news